Edward Community Radio, KMUD Garberville, 91.1 FM in HD1, KMU Eureka, 88.1 FM in HD1,
KLAI Laytonville, 90.3 FM on the web at kmud.org and a shelter cover at 99.5 on FM translator
K258BQ, 7 o'clock. Stay tuned for Ask the Herb Doctor.
[Music]
Hey you guys, welcome.
Well, welcome to this month's Ask the Herb Doctor. My name is Andrew Murray.
And my name is Sarah Johannesen Murray.
For those of you who have perhaps never listened to the shows before, they run every third Friday of the month from 7 to 8 PM with questions and a live call in from 7.30 until the end of the show at 8 o'clock.
As has become the custom here, we have Dr. Raymond Peek joining us and this month's topic is going to be the topic of small intestinal bacterial overgrowth with an overview of gastrointestinal motility and the common problems that many patients experience from chronic constipation through your diarrhea and some of those things that can be used to diagnose and some of those things that can be used to treat.
The number of you are interested in calling in from 7.30 on 707 923 3911.
Once again 707 923 3911 from 7.30 through 8 o'clock.
So once again, we're very pleased to have Dr. Raymond Peek join us and to share with his expertise. Dr. Peat, are you there?
Yes.
Hi, Dr. Peat. Thanks so much for joining us this month again. So for this June episode, June 2021, just a posterity, would you let people know your academic and professional background for perhaps those people who tuned in just now who may not have heard of you before?
I was studying and working in humanities, literature, painting various schools, and I decided to go back to graduate school in biology, physiology in 1968 and got the Ph.D. at University of Oregon in 1972.
And since then have been doing writing about physiology and counseling individuals and doctors about hormones and physiology and nutrition.
Okay. I know there's a wealth of information on your website, which we will give out at the end of the show for people who want to find out more about you.
Having been guided by you for 11 or 12 years now, I was just thinking over the previous years that we've done radio shows with you and spoken with you.
And having been very interested in the gut as a seat of good health, the ancients always talked about the seat of health being the digestion and assimilation and back in either very early times, you know, with the four humors and diagnosis of the disease that was used.
The rudimentary, elementary tract and its assimilation of food and excretion of waste has long been connected with health and ill health.
And I wanted just to go over what is known now. I think it has been for maybe 20 years, but maybe only in the last five years has there been a significant increase in the diagnosis of small intestinal bacterial overgrowth as a defined pathology,
which people settle with. And over the last 20 years, I've certainly spoken and consulted with a lot of people with gastrointestinal disturbance, either ranging from constipation or diarrhea or alternating IBS type irritable bowel syndrome type digestive complaints.
And I know you've mentioned for many different pathologies, serotonin as being a causative inflammatory mediator. And that's also been very enlightening in terms of serotonin in the common conception or the media conception that most people know about serotonin.
They think there's a positive hormone and actually it's very inflammatory. So I'd like to question you and get your feedback on your understanding of the pathogenesis and development of SIBO.
And just to say that they classify at this point in time under SIBO-C for constipation and SIBO-D for diarrhea. And there is a list of foods called the FODMAP guide to which I'd like to ask questions also because I know that some of the foods you're very interested in specific with dietary requirements
for people wanting to get better health and a lot of things that people eat now that they've told are healthy for them, especially any of those PUFAs that you've been rallying against for a long time now and the seeds and nuts and those kind of foods.
They appear on a FODMAP list and the FODMAP breaks, the F-O-D-M-A-P breaks down to fermentable oligosaccharides, disaccharides, monosaccharides, and then the polyols, the sugar alcohols.
So before we get into those kind of foods, what do you understand and how much relevance do you give to this type of SIBO with patients that are complaining of diarrhea or the complaining of constipation and what's your approach to it?
Everything can ferment if you aren't digesting it. Some people warn against the FODMAPs as causing problems because they ferment.
Others promote exactly the same carbohydrates and oligosaccharides and so on just because they do ferment and release short-chain fatty acids, acetate, butyrate, and propionate in particular.
And one doctrine says that those are beneficial, stimulating things that prevent bowel cancer and so on.
Others point out that each one of those is a very serious potential toxin, and we do absorb them, and acetate, acetic acid, and butyrate acid, and propionic acid all have their potential value,
but they are also very well known as toxins.
So generally, I'm inclined to say to the people that prefer not to eat the things which can increase those potentially toxic or chain fatty acids because you can get all your nutrients with things that are resistant to fermentation.
The sugars, if you have normal digestive actions, the sugars should be absorbed very high in the small intestine.
Just shortly after leaving your stomach, they should be absorbed, and that area in very healthy people, the stomach and the whole small intestine are sterile.
The sicker a person is, the farther up the small intestine from the colon, the farther up the bacteria and leather microbes can invade and set up housekeeping.
Some people with very weak digestion will actually have fermentation going on in their stomach.
So if they eat sugar or carbohydrate, they can get drunk and have alcohol production going on right in their stomach.
Interesting. You said the small intestine could or should be sterile in comparison to the colon, which we recognize as being the major production of proliferative and populated area compared to anything else you can think of, really.
You're saying that the small intestine should essentially be relatively sterile?
Yeah, the very healthy -- something like 15 or 20% of the population who are very healthy have a sterile small intestine.
And the sicker a person is, it tends to increase with age as the metabolic rate slows down.
The farther up in the small intestine, you find more and more bacteria living closer and closer to the stomach as a person develops poor digestion.
So because of poor motility, increased transit time and aging and decreased energy, the colonic bacteria then would have a chance to migrate upwards?
Yeah, the digestive fluids and the enzymes should discourage growth, if not just directly killing yeast and bacteria and parasites.
Okay, you're listening to Ask Your Herb, Dr. K. M. E. D. Galvigul, 91.1 FM. From 7.30 until 8 o'clock at the end of the show, you're invited to call in with questions.
Dr. Ray Peat, we're discussing small intestinal bacterial overgrowth, generalized inflammatory processes in the GI tract, and certainly some supplemental improvements that can be used, both herbal as well as some antibiotics.
But yeah, the number is 707-923-3911, and Dr. Raymond Peat is joining us.
Dr. Peat, to go through, again, how they classify SIBO-C and SIBO-D, they talk about hydrogen dominant, the bacteria that produce hydrogen dominant and the bacteria that produce methane.
And they talk about hydrogen dominant bacterial colonies, which are not supposed to be there. That's the whole point.
Associating the patient's symptoms with a diarrheal type SIBO, and then methane dominant species of bacteria that shouldn't be there, specifically associated with constipation.
I think that's mainly because methane is an anesthetic and slows bowel contractions, and it slows down all biological processes and decreases the metabolic rate.
So it's natural. It should tend towards constipation.
So, for the 20% of people have sterile intestines, what should the rest of us do?
80% of the population that doesn't have a sterile small intestine, what are we to do to help keep the bacterial overgrowth down in our small intestine?
Do you remember Dennis Burkett, who studied the diet effects and a particular type of tumor in Africa?
He popularized the use of a high fiber diet in the U.S. when he reported on the health benefits of the African diet and pointed out that Africans on their typical diet has a 12-hour transit time
for the average American has a 72-hour transit time, half a day versus three days for something to get processed and get out of view.
And so naturally, the African with the very short duration doesn't give putrefaction or fermentation a chance to go very far.
And the famous people who popularized yogurt in the diet as a way to suppress putrefaction.
For example, Metchnikoff and Bogle mallets early in the 20th century and end of the 19th century, they studied different animals that had short or long lifespans.
And they argued that the animals with a short intestine, a colon that just very quickly eliminated and didn't store for a long time the processed food, those were the long-lived animals.
Those with a long intestine and a long retention of the putrefying material in the intestine, those were shorter-lived.
So I saw hypothyroidism as one of the predisposing factors to SIBO in the population along with things like chronic pancreatitis and motor disorders like Parkinson's disease and fibromyalgia.
I saw IBS and fibromyalgia were fairly intimately linked and there was cause for investigating gastric or intestinal dysmotility with fibromyalgia patients.
But Parkinson's, that's interesting from a motor neuron perspective in terms of slowing muscular contraction along the GI tract or the constipation side of it.
Yeah, I think it's the constipation leading to the neurological problem. And traditionally they've been thinking of Parkinson's disease as a deficiency of dopamine, but dopamine and serotonin are an antagonistic pair.
And really the evidence, I think, more strongly indicates that Parkinson's is related to a serotonin excess than just a dopamine deficiency.
And a few people have argued that serotonin can't get from your intestines, your brain, but there is actual evidence that if you have an excess, an undetoxified amount of serotonin in the bloodstream, it can get into the brain and shift the balance away from dopamine.
And you've always said that the bulk of the serotonin produced is produced in the bowel, correct?
Ninety-five percent of it.
Yeah, okay.
And it's produced the serotonin where thought is what we've been told for the last 30 years that serotonin is the feel-good hormone and it's good for you.
But you view serotonin as a major inflammatory compound and actually the antidepressants that are supposed to be increasing serotonin, they've now retracted that statement and scientists are now saying that serotonin is not blocked by antidepressants like SSRI.
So how did that go wrong there and why is serotonin so inflammatory?
Its natural function in the bowel is to cause contractions and secretion when the bowel is irritated.
Irritation can be mechanical or chemical or biological, but the intestine knows it wants to get rid of something toxic and harmful.
So it produces serotonin that causes intense contractions and secretions and should wash the toxin out of the bowel.
But if you get a chronic inflammation and irritation, you just get a chronic moderate excess of serotonin that can cause usually just periodic cyclic diarrhea alternating with constipation.
So everyone who has had car sickness can relate to the feeling of high serotonin where your intestines are cramping and you feel nauseous. That's all from serotonin, correct?
Yeah, and one of the effects of serotonin is anxiety. That's now being more and more recognized rather than sleep-inducing. It can cause insomnia and anxiety and the bowel has a big role in that.
So what do you think Dr. P, if I can question you about some of the, I guess we'll start with the FODMAP kind of criteria that the medical industry use as guidance and then ask you a little bit about the breath testing results.
There seems to be somewhat disparaging in terms of they're not completely conclusive by any means, but in conjunction with symptoms can lead to a diagnosis and then perhaps the treatment options will be more fairly squared away towards solving it.
But in terms of the foods that they talk about that are predisposing to these fermentable oligosaccharides and dying monosaccharides, I think avoidance of many of them is very reasonable.
They recommend against beans and lentils, for example, and nuts and wheat and rye. All of those things have other harmful effects as well as the fermentable carbohydrates.
But they do this milk. I mean, that's the thing. And it's not all dairy because they say that even butter and cheese is very low in FODMAP equivalents and that cow's milk essentially encusted and things that are made from milk are quoted as high.
And I work with a lot of people who want to, they are fairly sure that they are lactose intolerant and obviously a large mainstay of your nutritional advice, which is very supportive and produces a balanced diet in terms of vitamins and nutrients from a fairly select source of foods.
Milk is one of those food groups for which you are a big advocate of drinking milk. And then, how do you feel about people that come over with a "milk" intolerant?
Because most published papers seem to suggest that most people can actually drink a reasonable amount of milk and it's not until they're drinking large amounts of milk that the FODMAP components of the milk are a problem.
Yeah, I think there's a kind of cultist fear of milk that gets mixed up with the research.
And even lactose intolerant people can tolerate a moderate amount, a small amount.
Especially if they start with a small amount, right? Dr. P, if they serve a small amount every day and increase it, then they will start developing over the period of two to four weeks lactase, which is an enzyme required to digest lactose.
But if they haven't been drinking milk, your body won't make enough lactase to digest the glass all of a sudden.
Yeah, there were studies done in ethnic Chinese people in California introducing milk to people who thought they were lactose intolerant. And in a few weeks, taking maybe half a glass at a time, they were able to induce the enzymes.
There's probably nothing in the body that isn't inducible given the appropriate circumstances.
The babies need to process the milk diet. And if they totally go without milk, then it's natural that they would adapt away the digestive enzymes relevant to milk.
But the experiments show that so far, everyone can induce, again, the lactase enzymes.
So for somebody with, for example, people that will disclose that they notice a definite change in bowel habits when they are drinking milk and seem to imply that the milk is tending in them to produce kind of pellet stools.
I mean, that's not the type of constipation that we are talking about associated with SIBO constipation. But what do you think is happening in that instance in terms of their bowel bacteria?
You think it's a bowel bacteria that are responsible for changes in the stool itself, or are there any other mechanism by which the proteins in the milk may be?
There are several possibilities, including the pasture, the foods that the cow gets. Sometimes they are very allergenic, and the person with allergies to those plants, if the cow is eating them, the milk will trigger those allergies.
Especially like if someone is very gluten sensitive and the cow is fed wheat, then it can come through the milk and make a person react poorly to that milk.
Right. And with breast milk, if the mother is eating a lot of allergenic foods, peanuts, for example, the baby will often get constipated.
Okay. So looking at possible diagnostic techniques for people that would be interested in taking this conversation further, if those people that are listening perhaps have really had a bow of fairly chronic GI disturbance leading to either chronic diarrhea and/or chronic constipation with little changing it in terms of anything they never tried.
Checking their body temperature is a good first step because hypometabolism, usually because of thyroid deficiency, sometimes from other nutrient deficiencies, but the hypometabolism lowers your body temperature at the same time, makes your tissues oversensitive.
So just by increasing your body temperature, getting enough easily absorbed glucose and fructose from sucrose, for example, the heat-producing effect of those carbohydrates can be enough to raise your body temperature, reduce the inflammation, and make your intestines better.
And make your intestines go more smoothly.
Let me ask you this then. All the papers that I've read that I've looked at of SIBO, really from 2003 until 2021, that have been done very recently, seem to agree on a microbiome that has been deranged, and they look at two particular species of bacteria, the proteobacteria and the firmicutes.
The kind of the sericea, klebsiella, and the pheromonas species of bacteria, saying that in patients with SIBO, the relative decrease in the firmicutes bacteria with an increase in the proteobacteria and the converse in non-SIBO patients.
Do you think there's anything, I was asking a question about Cascara and bowel antibiotic activity of Cascara, but do you think there's anything, what would you think of in terms of wanting to, and it brings up the other question I was going to ask about probiotic use, and how I think perhaps some people may have experimented with probiotics and gotten definite changes in bowel habits and sometimes not for the good.
But in terms of looking at the bacterial colonies that they've done studies on with SIBO and non-SIBO patients, they seem to have a definite consensual agreement on these two particular types of bacteria being in deranged proportions.
Would you be looking at anything other than an antibiotic, which is what they now, coming up with, they've said this antibiotic is particularly effective in doing, basically cleansing the bowel, but would you think of anything else, and that's why I mentioned Cascara and/or probiotics, and what do you think about their use in gastrointestinal disorders like SIBO or IBS?
Well, the Cascara accelerates the movement through the intestine, as well as reducing inflammation and maintaining oxidative energy production, but completely indigestible fiber, specifically cellulose.
The bulk effect can stimulate peristalsis and speed the movement through the intestine, reducing the chance for toxic fermentation, and making sure that your nutrients, calcium and vitamin D, are anti-inflammatory necessities.
Thyroid is anti-inflammatory, and the flavonoids, one of the reasons I recommend orange juice and milk is that they are both good sources of flavonoids without any of the toxic irritants that you find in some of the flavonoid-rich foods, leaves,
and some green vegetables that are rich in flavonoids also contain irritants, but orange juice is a very wide-spectrum anti-inflammatory and energy-producing food.
So I think the whole premise about eating foods that don't feed bacteria, like avoiding the refined processed grains and starches, is that then you'll have a reduction in bacteria in your small intestine as well as your large intestine,
and that's why you also recommend antibacterial foods like grated raw carrot, bamboo shoots, well-cooked mushrooms, oat bran in some instances to help increase the transit time as well as to act as a natural, gentle antimicrobial in both places,
because they'll be antimicrobial in the small intestine as well as the large intestine, correct?
And aspirin sometimes is a big help to decrease the bacterial activity.
You all have a caller.
Okay, good. Well, let me just start by saying this. You're listening to Ask Your Herb Dr. K. Medigalahville 91.1 FM. It's now 7.30 or thereabouts, and you're welcome to call in with questions for Dr. Raymond Peat.
And the number is 707-923-3911, and we have our first caller. Where are you from? What's your question?
Yes, sir. I'm calling from Redwood, California. I eat primarily 70% vegetables, 20% dairy, cheese, yogurt.
You can also make a homemade flax soda bread, and then the other 10% is like salad dressings. This is like my summertime eating method, and I use a sweetener that is stevia.
And when I usually finish off the meal, there's usually a tiny trace of some sort of sweetener like sugar or some other sweetener, honey, that may be in that.
So I finished off the meal with -- I'm going to butcher this Latin word, so pardon me -- "pa de arco." And it's an Amazonian --
Sure. Tapaburi. Tapaburi in protagonist.
So the question was, is that good?
Okay, well, everyone has different ideas about good nutrition, but 70% vegetable.
I know, Dr. Peat, you would definitely recommend well-cooking those, and 20% dairy. I'm not too sure what you think about that, I will know.
And obviously, from a herbal point of view, pa de arco has been well known as an anti-inflammatory, anti-cancer.
And in fact, last month's radio show we mentioned pa de arco and those dark red pigments that come from either a ethanol extraction or even simply decopting the herb
and how they have an electronic activity that is a very anti-inflammatory activity.
And this substance is lapachyl and others that have been isolated.
Dr. Peat, as a mainstay, nutritional breakdown, 70% veg, 20% dairy, soda bread, and very, very little sugars in the form of stevia.
I'm not sure that stevia is safe in large quantities, but a small amount is probably okay.
And soda bread, does that mean that it's a baking powder quick-rising?
That tends to leave most of the gluten intact.
But if it agrees with your intestine, doesn't cause inflammation, then that means your bowel health is pretty good.
And cooked, very well cooked vegetables are fine if a person doesn't have any problem with them.
The one thing I would think with an analysis of that is the protein.
I'm not sure where your protein is coming from besides the dairy.
Do you include eggs in your diet and/or any type of shellfish or other nutrient-rich proteins?
Engineer, I don't know if we have the caller on the line still, but they hung up on it.
Okay. Well, maybe that caller is not on the air anymore. I'm not too sure.
So the engineer is not responding with the fact that they are or aren't.
No, they're not. They hung up.
Okay. Okay. Well, anyway, let me just say once again, you're listening to ask your doctor.
Can you de-galve for 91.1 FM from now until the end of the show?
You're invited to call into questions related or unrelated to this month's subject of SIBO.
Small intestine, bacterial overgrowth, GI upset, number 07, 9233911.
Okay. Actually, this caller came back.
Okay. Go ahead, son.
Hi, caller.
Yes, are you there?
Yes.
You can hear me. Okay, great.
Can you hear Dr. Peat's answer?
Yes. I just wanted to answer his question.
He asked if the bread was baked.
If I had any distress, no.
Our family, a lot of our family are Scottish Irish, so it's something that's –
it's been a tradition, our family, for a very long time since my father.
And the other question was – well, you go ahead. I'm sorry.
No, that's okay. I just was wondering if – yes.
Protein, do you have – do we include eggs in your diet or other –
Yes. Yes, I eat a lot of eggs.
Okay. I don't know if that was included in the 20% dairy.
Well, that was included in the other 30%, you know, like the salad dressing,
the miscellaneous cheese, et cetera. That was part of that 30%.
Okay. Okay, good. Well, thanks for your call, and I hope you have a good night.
Thank you.
Dr. Peat, to just wrap up on the SIBO diagnosis and/or then further on treatment
before we get into the other subject here that I think we'll begin with,
but then we'll wrap up and talk more extensively on next month
in terms of transhumanism and the coming change in corporate structures
of treating us as people with medicines, other questionable medicines.
What do you think about the use then?
Obviously, there's one particular antibiotic used which is getting pretty good success
in treating SIBO by deranging, again, bowel bacteria.
Do you think probiotics that are labeled probiotics,
we have typical species that would normally reside in the bowel
as being positive in terms of recolonizing and safely changing the floor,
because it really is a balancing act which does not want any unwanted bacteria
to take out permanent residence.
That's exactly how SIBO starts in the first place.
What do you think of antibiotics?
I know we all agree that antibiotics are a very good form of treatment
for a lot of different things, but antibiotics and recolonization.
There are several bacteria, in particular some fungus,
that produce antibiotics themselves.
So they are a combination of probiotic and antibiotic.
They kill off a lot of harmful bacteria by antibiotics that they are producing.
But you can usually tell within a few hours if an antibiotic supplement
is going to help your digestive symptoms.
I think there's too much rigmarole in the diagnosis of digestive problems.
A lot of people have forgotten or never realized
that tapping your abdomen in different places,
you can identify whether you have a fluid accumulation or just gas.
You can identify a pocket of gas.
Sometimes it's where you wouldn't expect it to be.
It should be just in the colon area.
But if you're getting gas throughout your small intestine,
that will make your whole belly resound like a watermelon.
Just to confirm this, most people don't think that gas production,
obviously apart from its social disagreement,
is a problem that you should not produce gas, period, right?
I mean, there's nothing good about it.
No, and in fact, too much methane has those stasis-producing effects
leading to constipation.
And the diagnosis, if you find methane in your breath or coming out of your skin
and so on, it doesn't prove that you have methane-producing bacteria
because our own mitochondria, when they're under stress,
like in the presence of drinking too much alcohol,
our own mitochondria produce considerable amounts of methane.
So any stress can lead to methane appearing in all of our secretions.
So when you mentioned different fungi that can act as a probiotic and an antibiotic,
are you referring to species like the Saccharomyces boulardii?
Yeah.
Or are you thinking of other species?
No, that's the only one I know of.
Okay, so what do you think about...
Let me quickly ask you what you think about garlic
and allicin extract-rich garlic, because in England,
there's a company that's been producing this for some time now,
and I've got a lot of fans there about it
in terms of correcting intestinal dysbiosis.
Obviously, it's got a very strong sulfur moiety attached to it,
which is credited in some of its activity.
But I'm right in thinking that you believe that a lot of people
are fairly reactive to garlic in terms of its irritating effects
and not just its social effects.
But what do you think about the compound anacin
and garlic in general, the sulfhydryl compounds?
Yeah, those hot compounds can be harmful to your stomach
and an intestine if you eat large amounts of them.
They do kill bacteria, but they also can kill your digestive system,
epithelial cells.
I think the highest rate of stomach cancer in the world is Bhutan.
My friend visited Bhutan, and their diet consists of a lot of chili peppers,
and they have the highest rate of stomach cancer.
Yeah, Central America has a lot of stomach cancer associated with hot chilies.
Okay, well, I just wanted to bring out the other compounds
that would be useful in terms of its antibacterial effect.
And certainly, there are papers written that suggest
that Berberis vulgaris contained in the exploit berberine
are very useful in the treatment of SIBO.
And to some extent, Hydrastis, golden seal containing berberine also
is used, but berberine hydrochloride, I think, is the main component.
Okay, so let's just open up the topic for those who are listening
and have listened to the previous 9 months or 10 months or so
that we've been discussing COVID-19.
And all of the nefarious activity, both in the origin of it and the cover-up,
and then the cover-up for the simple, safe, and effective treatment of it
rather than any biological agent, which is called a vaccine,
but which defies any of the parameters, the vaccine's definition.
The coming transhumanism, I've heard people like Alex Jones in the past
a long time ago when I used to listen to him.
He talked about transhumanism 10, 15 years ago, and here we are.
And we see people like Elon Musk rising to these kind of heights
through his industries becoming a figure of public importance.
Obviously, he's cautioning us about artificial intelligence, certainly.
But the things like implantable chips that you put in your brother,
he's talking about neurobiology and wiring people's brains
to these implantable chips that will give them "superhuman power."
And part and parcel of the COVID-19 debate lies in the technology used
to produce this experimental drug, which they call the vaccine, the mRNA vaccine.
But your thoughts on the changes that society is going through,
and it's undoubtable that we can ignore or deny,
that society has gone through probably one of the greatest upheavals
psychologically and socially, and has happened really since either
probably the Second World War, but it's been a long time
since such a great upheaval has happened.
And now we're being told that the platform, the mRNA platform
upon which this experimental drug has been cheaply and easily
and quickly scaled up to such numbers that they can distribute it worldwide.
The collaboration with two other countries, Italy
and the other country was Switzerland, I think.
But the manufacture of these mRNA vaccines,
what we're calling vaccines is mRNA experimental drugs,
is going to increase to any and every disease that you can think of.
And yet the whole platform, the mRNA platform,
is, quote-unquote, giving us over to genetic changes
that are essentially going to put us at risk as a species moving forward,
and it's not going to stop.
I've been for several months looking for what the actual scientific rationale
might be for shifting from traditional vaccines killed or inactivated bacteria
or viruses, for example.
What the reason was for this sudden shift of all of the vaccine companies
towards a nucleic acid.
Well, they want to say time, don't they?
What?
They want to argue that the time to produce that is why they've done it,
because it's so quick to do it this way.
I mean, isn't that the...?
I don't think there has been any clear scientific explanation for why they did it.
You can shortcut all of the traditional methods of making vaccines.
What they did was skip ordinary animal and safety testing to speed it up.
But when you look at the individuals behind these companies,
you see that years ago, they were talking about genetic engineering,
and in justifying why they have come up with the RNA vaccines,
they are describing them as changing our genetic operating system,
treating us like a computer, and simply improving our operating system,
changing the genome in the context of all of these people justifying
why they would use nucleic acids instead of traditional activators of the immune system.
So we are becoming the genetically modified organism.
We might vote to block the production of genetically modified organisms,
enhance food, but now we are becoming the genetically modified organism.
And when Tony Fauci heard the suggestions of the evidence that the RNA can be copied back,
reversed, transcribed into our DNA, he said that doesn't happen or can't happen, and so on.
He indicated either total ignorance of 50 years of nucleic acid research
showing that everyone contains the reverse transcriptase,
which whenever RNA enters the cell, a foreign type of it,
it's able to be transcribed into DNA, and the DNA doesn't have to enter the nucleus even.
It can be a perpetual part of the cell, an inherited part of the cell,
even though it was transcribed from a foreign added RNA or other nucleic acid.
So they might try to tell you that it's not permanent and your body will stop producing it,
but what you're saying is 50 years of research has shown that these changes can very easily become permanent.
Yes, and there have been demonstrations that our excess album system,
which is designed to create these little particles like viruses to communicate proteins
and genetic information from one cell to other cells that aren't differentiated properly,
an internal regulatory system of our own genes,
that has been demonstrated to be open to receiving foreign DNA and RNA
and packaging it in exosomes so that we participate.
Our own mechanism becomes like a virus factory copying and spreading the foreign DNA or RNA.
This is exactly what Tal Zaks, the former CEO of Moderna, was quoted as saying,
that same thing in 2017 when he was interviewed.
There's an article online that is basically a transcript of the interview
and mentioning that this platform, the mRNA platform, is going to be so rapidly scaled up,
it's so cheap, it's so quick, and it's going to be the future.
He had questions about the whole thing about integrating DNA or from RNA into us
and actually changing us genomically, and we would have hereditary consequences.
And he said the same thing that you've said about you.
You've said that it's not possible, it doesn't happen, don't worry about it.
He's actually an oncologist, and he was proposing genetic engineering as cancer treatment.
And years ago, I think Biden was the instigator or the figurehead for the idea,
the Cancer Moonshot, they called it, which was based on basically genetic engineering on an individual basis
to change the genes of your cancer.
So the other thing that I kind of thought about, we've mentioned this since March,
since we just started doing the ask your doctor shows based around COVID,
and just showing all the time that this mortality was actually very low
and that there was definitely optional treatments like hydroxychloroquine and ivermectin
from the very beginning, and the whistleblower doctors who said that these things were effective,
and then they carried on talking about these same treatments, which are very inexpensive,
very safe, and very effective, and we don't need this experimental drug.
Leave me on, think about the whole, you know, Covis Alimentarius
and the World Economic Forum being a platform upon which governments who,
well, not will, probably are superseding citizens of countries in tandem,
in concert with other governments, and it is certainly not a conspiracy theory, folks.
It's a reality, and there's plenty of evidence to show and support that.
We're not spouting scary stories here, it's just factual evidence.
I think, as you mentioned, Dr. Peat, probably in the next two to five years,
we'll get borne out with any increased deaths that would come about from either
exposure to other regular foods as a result of the enhanced activity of the immune system
through this experimental drug, but basically to life in general,
in our lifestyles, being forced into a certain direction.
And this is the humanism part of what I want to get into with you next month
in more detail, and just lay it out for people, because the shows are listened to,
and certainly the audio archives are listened to, and the internet is full
of these interviews that we've done with you on YouTube and other areas.
So it's not like it's going to go away, and it's been laid down for right now,
and people will hear it through.
As time goes on, the truth will come out a little bit like some of the atrocities
of the Second World War and other instances where this activity was shouted about,
but no one listened, but afterwards it all came out,
and they had to agree that what was being shouted was actually the truth.
So thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Peat.
Okay, thank you.
It's three minutes to the hour, so rather than anything else carrying on,
I'd rather give people your information,
point them to where they can find out more about you,
and to thank you so much for your time on the show tonight.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Peat. Good night.
Good night.
So for people who've listened to the show this evening,
more can be found out about Dr. Peat and his 40, 50-year work here on Earth.
His website is www.raypeat.com,
and you can find out lots of reference articles that he's written.
He's been working in this field of alternative science
for the narrative for 30 years and more,
working with people and counseling, et cetera,
and we've certainly enjoyed our time with him.
He's been very eye-opening in lots of things that we thought were true,
but have been educated beyond that,
and now seeing that we are not the conspiracists,
but actually the people with some of the more important information.
So my name is Andrew Murray.
My name is Sarah Johansson Murray.
Thank you for listening this evening, and we hope you have a great solstice.
And we can also be looked at.
Our website is www.westerandbotanicalmedicine.com.
And until the third Friday of next month, July,
we will be picking up on this transhumanism subject
and looking at particularly the science that's pushing us forward in this direction.
I'm not saying we will want to go in it,
but I think unfortunately he's going to be taking people.
So until this same time, next month, the third Friday of next month, good night.
Good night.
[Music]
Okay, so I failed to read the cards at the top of the hour,
so I want to let you know that Herbal MedRx creates organic herbal products,
including bath and body oil, salves, deodorants, herbal teas,
CBD products, essential oil blends, and more.
Visit www.herbalmedRx.com to see all products and events.
You can reach through lekasha at herbal med rx by phone